hello oh hello am i speaking to
professor hans oh hello my name is Adam
Smith calling from nobelprize.org the
official website of the Nobel Prize
first of all congratulations on the
award of the Nobel Prize thank you very
much it's a great honor now what was
your first reaction on hearing the news
oh well certainly I'm very much pleased
and very much honored it's the first
Nobel Prize awarded for cancer therapy
for many years what message do you think
this sends as you say the fourth
treatment certainly this is the first
time and I think the many people tried
very hard to cure the cancer but
fortunately we jima listen and myself
[Music]
studied this check money inhibitor
therapy I mean the prints we discover
the principal and this is really working
so for me it's more than happy to see
many patients often I can see and
telling me you saved my life that is the
most enjoyable and I would say I'm very
pleased to hear that what I have done is
really meaningful it shows that you
never really know which way things will
go in research because you didn't set
out to discover oh no well it's such a
complex system it's totally different
from the engineering we cannot design
many people try to find the therapy for
cancer but all failed and myself I never
expected my research working on immunity
them will lead to the cancer therapy but
so in a sense I'm very fortunate but I
also thought about it so you know you
have to try many things and if you're
lucky you can hit anybody you have to
pursue that's my area and what is your
hope for the future of immune checkpoint
inhibitors well there are still several
problems but two most important one is
still only 30% of patients responding so
we wish to have some biomarkers to
predict whether he or she is responsive
or not
secondary different we wish to improve
the efficacy of this treatment and
actually this is a target of many many
scientists in the company so I believe
these two problem will be solved in
[Music]
future that's a very hopeful message and
indeed I think the awarded the prize is
a very hopeful sign for a very large
number of people around the world today
I think so it's encouraging and we need
the power of many many people to push
this therapy in really satisfactory
level this is just beginning of the
whole story well thank you very much
indeed
we we greatly look forward to welcoming
you to Stockholm in December it's very
exciting to talk to you and I once again
many many congratulations thank you very
much I really appreciate